it's march madness which means on april
seven will have a new college basketball
champion it would be plenty of winners
and losers off the court the tournament
draws more ad dollars in the NBA
playoffs it draws more ad dollars than
the Super Bowl of TV advertising which
is the Super Bowl CBS and Turner agreed
to pay almost 11 billion dollars over 14
years for exclusive rights to the
tournament that's almost 900 games for
every game played each regional
conference gets a payment from the
n-c-double-a of about 250 thousand
dollars those conferences generally pay
that money to the schools competing and
they can use it however they see fit but
the payments are spread over six years
so there's a big incentive for schools
to go deep in the tournament every year
last year nike had its gear on 52 of the
68 tournament teams Wichita State made
it to the final four last year and Nike
sweetened its deal this year the team is
undefeated and all eyes are on them and
their nike gear some eighty-six percent
of workers say they'll spend at least
part of their day checking out the
tournament which equates to about 1.2
billion in lost productivity
Warren Buffett's Berkshire Hathaway is
ensuring a 1 billion dollar offer to
anyone who submits a perfect bracket
last year ESPN collected about 8 million
brackets none of them more perfect the
sage of Omaha doesn't think anyone is
lucky enough or smart enough to go all
the way the FBI estimates Americans will
illegally wager 2.5 billion dollars on
the tournament this year that includes
the ten dollars you're gonna lose in the
office pool